more than half a million people in
england were pinged by the nhs test and
trace app in a week that is the highest
figure recorded
and a rise of 46 percent from the
previous week
our health correspondent ashish joshi
joins me now hello to you arshish
and this is before next monday's
reopening
yeah that's what will concern the
government and the prime minister you
know we've been hearing a lot
about the the vaccine and the greatest
protection it offers everyone but
i don't think the prime minister and his
advisers can
ignore or disregard these rising numbers
of infections
we know that england opens up fully
without restrictions next week we might
already be seeing the effects
or the after effects of the uh
socializing through the football the
euros which
we were told would happen but when we're
still
here in in the middle of a rising
caseload with the economy opening up
next week without restrictions
that will cause a lot of people to say
maybe now is not the right time those
calls are growing louder 4 000
scientists
writing in the lancet urging the prime
minister to reconsider
but the prime minister remains defiant
he says as long as we don't see
these infections materializing or
turning into hospitalizations and debt
in the numbers that we've seen them
before the warning is that we will see
rising hospitalizations and we will see
more people suddenly losing their lives
but we won't see them in the numbers
we've seen them in the previous two
waves then the country has to reopen
that is the argument
that the prime minister has put forward
also last week
you will recall many of the ministers
talking about the app
and and the need for it to be sort of
desensitized as it were because it was
pinging too many people
and now the the the app should be
changed because it doesn't really
take into effect that if two people who
are in close contact
they might have been pinged but they're
standing back to back in a well
ventilated area
and they might be fully vaccinated
therefore they shouldn't have to isolate
the isolation rules change in august but
that's still several weeks away and if
so many people are being pinged then at
the moment they are being asked
to self-isolate and that puts a lot of
pressure on the economy on businesses
and on employees this is the prime
minister's response of the
what will happen over the the next few
days and
why he is certain that the country
although
he thinks it's going to be very
difficult over the next few weeks the
country is in a position
to reopen fully